uh in energy you have to be very policy
sensitive because
everything depends on the tariffs that
you pay
the incentives and the penalties that
are out there if you do different things
[Music]
[Applause]
david orphan thank you so much for being
on my show 20 minute leaders
my pleasure good to be here i can't wait
forever here
yeah well first of all where are you
because this is not a virtual background
a lot of people have this as a virtual
background but you are actually there
i am uh right now staying in
potomac maryland which is a suburb of dc
i was actually born in potomac maryland
so it's
no kidding yes so we we are very close
to great falls park which is just
it's a national treasure as are all of
our national parks
wonderful well thank you so much for
taking the time to do this and i think
it's very
it makes a lot of sense that this is
your background given that you're an
expert in renewable energy and
and working in you know high ground com
in fast-growing companies that are
making
a real difference and in the world and
you know very
quick background stanford mba in the
graduate school
of business moving on use held numerous
executive positions
uh solar city nine dot uh so many others
that i missed along the way but i'd love
to hear a little bit about you from your
journey
going into the space terrific
so um i'd say um
the journey i can't say gee when i was a
business school student
or an undergraduate this is what i was
wanted to do in my life
each each thing is a response to the
needs opportunities
and creativity that i can bring to it
so i started life as a professional life
as a community organizer
in the jewish community in los angeles
working for the jcrc which brought in
some
values that i care deeply about i worked
in washington dc as an
on as a hill staffer and as an education
lobbyist
then i went to business school got a
entrepreneurial bug
uh started a few companies and then
ended up
um in 2006 sing the al gore movie
inconvenience truth and that was
eye-opening
uh both from the the this is around
climate change
as well as kind of the business
opportunities to create some interesting
sustainable businesses so by
a little work and a bunch of discussions
and happenstance i came up with a
pretty good idea uh together with some
other people
to do a solar leasing program so instead
of somebody having to make a massive
investment
on having to buy something that they've
never bought before
um and they think is a good idea but you
know it's a it's a hard decision to make
instead change the ownership model work
with some of the incentives that are out
there
and uh and create something new and i
i did that and i have been fortunate to
be able to
kind of take that idea and ones that
spun off of it
and spend the last i don't know 14 years
working in
energy with fantastic people
unbelievable and you know
one of the things that have always
intrigued me as an entrepreneur i'm
thinking about
solar and i'm thinking about this
transition of how do you get
you know even when the technology
matures how do you get people to buy
into this the average citizen and i
think a lot of it ties back to the way
people manage their money and and how
they think about
expenses and rewards because essentially
the cell if i'm if i understand it
correctly
of let's say solar panels on the roof
the cell is you're going to pay a lot of
money now
you're going to return the money slowly
and
within a few years they're going to
reach a break-even point
and then you're going to start saving
money but it's a very different thing
than i'm you're not saying
here i'm going to give you cash you're
saying you're going to lose less
right it's a different mindset it's a
difference yeah
and and you know a lot of risk uh and
uh a lot of what i think about is risk
and reward right and kind of behavioral
economics
so if you basically take you know we all
have these little things here right
these uh uh these cell phones and
we know we are going to be subscribing
to expensive services the rest of our
lives
yeah and if somebody came up to us and
said gee
wouldn't it be nice if you just put up
thirty thousand dollars and we will
that's going to pre-pay the rest of your
life of cell phones
you may say that's a terrific idea but
instead i'd rather spend a thousand
dollars a year on it
over the next 40 years hopefully
maybe 50 if i'm pushing it um but
whatever that
whatever that period is i didn't so the
the telecom industry built out the
infrastructure
and made a compelling proposition to
customers to pay
by the month to pay by the day to pay
you know in
autos it's pay by the mile um and
that's basically what what how you get
uh new technologies adopted faster you
know like the old xerox machine it's
hard to sell it for
for five thousand dollars to an office
sell it for 10 cents a copy
go ahead all day long right okay that's
fascinating but so nevertheless
you're you become you watch the al gore
movie is that really the turning point
for you when you realize that there's a
huge problem in the world
and then you decide to spend the next 14
years working on these things
well i kind of knew there was a problem
in the world i just didn't know how i
connected
to it and so since then you've helped
all these positions
when did you join a solar city as vice
president
i joined solar city uh very in the very
early days
in um may of 2007
and uh seven wow and and so i had the
idea of a solar
leasing product um you know lyndon rives
and peter arrived the co-founders of
solarcity instantly got why financing
was important
and perhaps just as important elon musk
understood
that customer financing was important so
you know they basically said ah that's
the idea that we need to be able to go
from being a small company to being a
large company to being a massive company
that ended up getting 35 market share in
the united states which is just
unheard of unbelievable so so you
so so essentially as part of of solar
city
talk to me a little bit about this
journey because you're really in and you
have the privilege of being
and and in the as a pioneer and this
realm of of
transitioning a country and going solar
and seeing the technology develop and
seeing how customers interact with it so
and you're actually working on strategy
right within solar city so
how do you work on strategy in the
context of renewable energy
wow well you start by understanding what
the customers want and where where
markets
are in energy you have to be very
policy sensitive because everything
depends on
the tariffs that you pay the incentives
and the penalties that are out there if
you do different things
so you have to understand and it's a
very interdisciplinary area which is why
i like it so
you know some of my time i get to be you
know what is strategy it's a combination
of
economics of consumer behavior
risk and psychology finance
energy hardware devices and
accounting and policy
and i'm not an expert at any one of
those things
but i have enough experience and kind of
just see
or observe things in the world where you
can combine those
and if you do that you can come up with
some interesting solutions and what i
loved about solarcity was
they let me create this solution
encouraged me to create it put their
muscle behind it it changed the
organization it changed the industry
and that was a commitment from
leadership
and lyndon rive in particular to
uh understand uh that we needed to sell
things differently we needed to approach
the consumer differently
uh and it was a really interdisciplinary
approach and
it was a big risk uh i thought it was um
obvious that it would work and there
were months and months that was hard to
do and in particular
when we started this remember i said we
joined in 2000 and i joined solarcity
right as they had started in 2007.
that was right before the big crash of
2008.
so to go to the wall street banks and to
say
we'd like you to buy a portfolio of 5
rooftop solar systems during the midst
of a housing
crisis that we have never seen before
and the security on this is going to be
a little less than
you would get on a second mortgage you
know we had a lot of doors slammed in
our face
but we had good people um uh on our team
and
very good uh people on the morgan
stanley team at the time
and we were able to get deals done and
that set a
trajectory for uh uh for me for the
business
uh and for the industry unbelievable and
in the in thr
through solarcity did you ever cross
paths also with elon and get to
and get to hear a little bit about his
his perspective and how he saw
how how he sees the industry uh i did
uh and uh elon is a very bright guy
uh much more introverted than uh kind of
his public persona on twitter etc
yeah he's really an engineer
and he sees what is possible and then
doesn't understand why you go from
um what is possible to why can't you do
it
tomorrow let's get this thing out there
let's push he because he started at
paypal
he actually had a natural um
let's just say dislike or suspicion of
banks
uh he would he said you know basically
you're gonna go on
go to banks you're going to explain this
idea you're going to explain to them how
they can make a lot of money
and they're not going to know what to do
with this or they're going to try to
steal your idea
so he's a you know incredibly bright guy
and he was very supportive of
kind of helping to steer the ship
towards a
a mass customer experience he just wants
everything done
really quickly perfectly
yeah and he and yesterday and and as a
result of his management style
he gets a lot out of people and uh you
know everybody who's worked in an
organization
uh for him for a period of time will
tell you that um
yeah they contributed uh if they didn't
contribute they were out
and and they gave a lot of themselves
and that's
you know call that a management um
um bonus or a management characteristic
uh you work really hard i mean i think
at the end
you know a lot of people are working on
ventures and i see a lot of and i'm you
know i'm thinking constantly about
things that i want to do later on as an
entrepreneur myself
that's part of the motivation for for
speaking to you here and getting this
inspiration
at the end you're talking about when
you're talking about changing the world
and actually changing the world not
writing that on a slide deck and saying
i'm going to revolutionize
x y z but actually going and doing it
you know i think that at the end you can
forgive a little bit of
it i obviously didn't experience this
myself but you can forgive a little bit
of hard work
and a little bit of pushing if he and
the results are showing but david
you know i'm talking to you now as a
young entrepreneur i'm going to go on my
own path i'm going to have to make some
difficult decisions on what i work on
how i work on it and with who
and i'd love to get you know a little
bit of insight into this world of
renewable energy which you're
an expert on by now what are some
what are some of the things that are
happening around the world in this
industry that i should be aware of
because honestly
it's not the sexiest thing in the
hallways of stanford right now and
probably not in a lot of places in the
world
so let's talk about renewable energy
right so um
there's so many different ways to uh
start to answer that question
good i'm saying we have about seven
minutes so we can talk about that
so we'll solve we'll solve it by that
not a problem
so i'm going to kind of just separate
kind of the
the grid connected world where we can
improve our energy sources
okay and the off-grid world and there
are
call it two billion people out there in
the world
today without reliable access to
electricity
without reliable access okay without
reliable access to electricity
so and some without electricity at all
but it's also the reliability if you
have electricity three or four hours a
day
that's a lot better than nothing but uh
you still
you know have uh have other needs so so
i would kind of start with the
ability to um uh
look at the world that is what we call
off-grid or
semi-off-grid and look at what it is
that can be done to bring electricity
and literally light to those people and
that's you know
maybe 250 million people in india
uh throughout latin america uh and in
africa
and their systems are going to be very
different they don't have all the
appliances because they don't want
electricity obviously
so you know bringing in a light having
them
also on a pay-as-you-go system i think
is really terrific and important and
whether that's
the lights for their house or their
their
in the village uh whether it's a light
for their uh
working place whether it's refrigeration
uh being able to
charge their their uh cell phones so
that's kind of
is that's one big area so we have so we
have electricity and
in many places around the world and we
have these systems is the problem
i want to know whether it's a chicken
and the egg problem do we have
the technology and we just have to spend
money to scale it and
implement it there or do we or are we
looking for
more financially viable solutions more
technologically savvy solutions to make
it more efficient
and because we don't have them yet
that's why we don't have the electricity
there
which one is it um so for
solar for wind for
bio gas we have the technology today
that is
plenty good to be able to make us much
much more energy independent
we still have to evolve we still have to
improve we still have to make
inverters better we have to capture more
hours of the of
of sunlight in different ways uh per
square foot that you're using
but the technology is there um i think
a second part of energy is storing it so
you can
you know have windmills till you know
wind turbines going all night long
offshore or in the midwest but that's
not where the
demand is that's not where the load is
so you have to be able to bring that
somewhere and it's really good to have a
you need storage and storage is coming
it's here
it's but the prices have to come down
and just like in solar panel solar
panels cost
10 percent of what they did when i
started
you know uh over a decade ago they're 10
now and we're going to get the same
thing with storage and we're going to
get other systems so
i think you know look i'm a mba i'm not
technical um i wish i could develop the
next generation of solar panel
or a chemical reaction that that brings
more energy better faster
that's not me that's a lot of smart
people using ai
or or or uh other ways to invent the
technologies and improve the
technologies
i look at the world from uh how do you
get people to adopt
what's the business model that you can
look at that says
i can get the on the one hand the end
user to adopt
and on the other hand somebody to
underwrite
the risk of that technology will work
and that person will pay for it
but you know but there's still why why
are there two billion people without
electricity if we have
solar wind water we have all these
we have all these possibilities why
aren't we just spending
the billions necessary and you know we
are spending them on on different things
but
why are we not spending them on on
providing electricity what are we
waiting for is this
a policy issue you know a governmental
bureaucracy issue is this a technology
issue
i say it is 90
government uh bureaucracy policy
you know not sending the grid into
areas that need the grid and if you go
to
these remote areas that have democracies
for example
you will often hear yes the power grid
is coming
vote for me i will get power to you i
will get electricity to you
and every few years when the election
comes up the same types of promises are
made
but then there's not the follow through
there's a technical challenge which is
you have to run wires and you have to
build infrastructure
and and come and and countries can do
that and states or provinces
can do that but it requires a level of
discipline
and working through things and
um it's incredibly slow i mean
if you look at america we didn't have
much electricity a hundred years ago
uh you know we built up the greatest
grid in the world uh and that was done
largely because of uh policies and
government support
and and um uh i'm not saying that
we're in in the same place in these
rural areas
uh but there's so much more that could
be done and i think business model
uh evolution is a part of what that is
um right so makes a lot of sense david
after so many years in this industry
what are you excited about today
tomorrow morning what are you going to
be working on that really excites you
new business models that basically take
policies economics
incentives customer behavioral things
we're working on some really interesting
things in new york city now
uh community energy and nine dot energy
is is leading the way and hopefully
come september we will bring on um
a seven and a half megawatt system which
will bring 60
million kilowatt hours a year onto the
grid for the next 25 years
and our users will be all over new york
city and it's going to support the grid
in unique ways
so i'm excited about i'm excited i'm
also excited about
more solar more electric vehicles
mopeds um like um
like uh electric mopeds like the rebel
system which is just amazing
uh i love uh scooters and docking
stations like the one swift
mile makes yeah it's just
it's just it's just there there's so
much cool stuff out there
uh and you know in this covet area we
kind of see a lot of
um there's a lot of problems and and
life is going to change
and one of the things things might
change is
how we use our vehicles and what types
of vehicles we use
and what streets are like and how much
of
and how much of our land we end up using
to park cars and to move cars you know
one of the most difficult things and i'm
looking at television you know i'm
riding here my bike in palo alto and
it's beautiful there's a bike lane
everywhere it's so wide and wonderful
and we have hundreds of scooters waiting
to be ridden
and it's i'm scared to death i want to
ride a scooter i want to ride my bike in
tel aviv but i can't
but i i do want to ask though so you
know we're both a part of j
ventures and and so we're looking at a
bunch of early stage companies
are we seeing an increase in companies
that are dealing with these problems
or or is there a shortage of of a of
good
talent that is trying to work with
electricity with mobility with
within renewable energy um
there's a lot of talent coming in
there's a lot of talent in the field
the key thing and the signals are going
to be
how will investors uh look
at these opportunities right and i think
you know
we have seen a lot of excitement on on
on vehicles on
revel which which i mentioned the
scooter craze one happened
you know it was a bubble from evaluation
side but it also proved the point
uh and then created the opportunities
for things like these docking stations
or for
a recharging economy so
um you know there will be uh electric
vehicle
and not just electric vehicles
autonomous vehicles uh
car cars that we could think of truck
lines that go around
uh on on various routes and that can
draft behind each other
in very short separation and
save on fuel costs
from water and it's not just uh it's not
just electricity it's also
on the water side and and other
resources that actually consume a ton of
electricity
um uh but there's there's
there's opportunities uh hopefully the
venture
crowd and adventure world and and and
they
uh have a lot of mind think in the um
in the venture world that they follow
each other and when the word gets out
that clean tech is great
like it was in the late bots then there
was a lot of investment and then all of
a sudden the word got out
it's tough we have to we don't know we
don't know enough so
i think that's going to happen what i'm
really excited about now is
uh kind of the combination of very large
commitments by companies to lower their
carbon footprint
and things that would have taken four
years to get through committees and
processes to do a
power purchase agreement for a solar
farm or whatever
now the whoever runs energy there if
they could show that it's a it's a
fair deal a good deal they're saving on
carbon and they're saving on money
they can get those through and that
combined with
things like the gates foundation and and
breakthrough energy
and other major foundations uh you know
the rockefeller family
uh folks who are saying you know what
got us here
won't get us there uh and where
we're heading from a climate site is is
is disastrous
uh we know this uh and uh
but there's a lot of fun solutions out
there and whether you're high high tech
yeah you can and and can develop
something big or figure out a better
model for the scooters
how to move the scooters how to build
lanes for the scooters how to signal
the one thing i'd love to throw out
there for the world that we need
desperately is a cheap
um dispensable or disposable
helmet that comes with every scooter
ride and
every little bike rental in in the city
uh that that happens because people like
you
like me go on tel aviv uh we go on these
scooters
and uh and we are less protected than we
know we should be
i completely agree david i need three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
three words to describe myself um
adventurous i love new adventures it's
why i'm an entrepreneur
and it's why i get to live in different
parts of the world
this is a hyphenated word uh values
driven
i do things that i are consistent with
the values and
work with people who are consistent with
the values that i hold
and um and indomitable
i i you may not know that word
uh i don't i don't know the word in
hebrew but indominable is
you just it's what entrepreneurs need to
be
they don't see blockades
as something that is insurmountable you
you keep going you keep working
you try this way you try that way and uh
my friend rich kelly uh uh uh gave me
that uh
uh that name and uh i like
indomitable so i love it there we go i
love it david thank you very much
thank you for the inspiration thank you
for that michael this is a
a pleasure allah kefak yeah
bye bye bye
you